Since I have the side that is opposite and the side that is adjacent, remember this is adjacent
and this is hypotenuse, that looks like tangent would be easiest.
Why don't you go ahead and calculate the tangent of this angle?
And I'm going to start calling it angle--I don't know--α. It seems like a good letter.
And I know the tangent of a is equal to the opposite over the adjacent.
And when I do this, I get about 0.8684 and that's really basically 0.869. We're very close to this.
I can actually figure out, hey, this must be a 41-degree angle more or less.
We're not at exactly 0.869 but close enough.
Using this fact, I can say with confidence that alpha is a 41-degree angle.
And now maybe you are seeing how we can use trigonometric ratios to calculate the angle
at which the sun's rays are striking the earth in a particular location.
We're making some serious progress. Before we move on, let's do one more practice problem.